hey guys what's going on there's going
to be a whole bunch of Marvel stuff
happening this next week so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and leave
all your requests for bonus videos in
the comments but it has been the best
weekend for comic book lovers we got new
guardians of the galaxy we got new
Justice League and we got a bunch of new
spider-man Home Coming there has been
all out marketing war between Marvel and
DC look at all these movies you think
you can upstage us by releasing the
first big trailer for your team up movie
well we're going to release a whole
bunch of stuff so they started releasing
Justice League posters for each of the
characters with really short teasers
like hey we're going to drop the first
Justice League teaser and as that was
happening Marvel coincidentally dropped
a giant PB spot and a whole bunch of
posters over those same couple of days
and then as things got on they started
doing the same thing with spider-man
homecoming in Tom Holland posted this
video once your front I'm Tom hall on
your friendly neighborhood spider-man
thank you so much for liking our
Facebook page and we hope you like all
the new content will be posted over the
next few days nasty buckle so you watch
that you wonder to yourself hey why have
they been posting all these spider-man
pictures within next to the Avengers
tower in New York City
why is Tom Holland telling the nation of
France in a facebook video that he's
going to be posting a whole bunch of
stuff really soon will one we're
approaching the four month anniversary
for the release date of spider-man
homecoming that's coming out July 7 so
it'll be four months this next week
meaning that they're ramping up for more
content to start posting when movies get
within a certain time window they really
ramp up their content so like Justice Li
just drop that big trailer but the movie
is not coming out till November so
there's not going to be a whole bunch of
Justice League posting but we have
guardians of the galaxy coming out in
May so there's been all kinds of
Guardian stuff posting every single week
like every week we've gotten a little
bit of new guardians a little bit of new
egos a living planet I just posted that
new trailer video so we're getting ready
for that cycle to start for spider-man
homecoming so Tom Holland is just
telling the international box office hey
we're getting ready to post a whole
bunch of crap you are going to love it
so get ready to freak out but as they
were posting these pictures they had
little one-line
with them homework can wait New York
can't straight a superhero quickest way
to get home as he's hanging on to the
overpass looking like he's trying to
hail a bus they're trying to tell you a
little bit about what some of the action
of the movie is going to be in some of
the locations so the big thing here I
think is the Avengers tower because we
see him with Tony Stark in what looks
like the New Avengers facility in
upstate New York at the last trailer so
you asked yourself what Spider Man doing
in upstate New York if he's bound to the
boroughs of New York City spider-man is
a very New York centric character he's
traveled around on a lot of big comics
but most of the spider-man movies had
been localized to New York City so it
makes sense if he's a little kid and
he's not flying in the jet all the way
overseas with Tony Stark to fight in a
big Avengers battle that he would stay
in New York City but we haven't been
back to the Avengers tower since
Avengers age of Ultron you know part of
the reason I think that they made the
New Avengers base was because they
needed more space because the team was
growing but also people would attack the
Avengers so if you're going to attack
them in the building is in the middle of
New York City the rest of New York City
is in pretty big danger so I think Tony
Stark wisely decided to take them out of
New York City so that every time some
petty thug came a-knockin or the
government they didn't have to worry
about hurting the rest of the people of
New York and because of design language
they move production of all the Marvel
movies to Georgia in this building that
they use as the Avengers base is like a
giant alley factory inside Georgia so
this is like a building that they just
add a little bit of CG to so they don't
have to build an entire city when
they're in Georgia it would be crazy
expensive from a CG perspective so like
if they wanted to do more New York City
they would ask you have to go film in
New York City which is what they did for
spider-man homecoming obviously they
filmed a lot in Queens they filmed a lot
in Manhattan so of the big locations
that we know in the spider-man movie
there's the Washington Monument so
that's some sort of class field trip
that they go on where he encounters the
vulture and there's sort of his home
borough of Queens where his school is
and then you have Manhattan proper where
the Avengers Tower is that's in Midtown
if you were wondering here he's
basically sitting on the East River here
I actually used to live off of the East
River when I lived in New York City
if you're wondering what the
yellowjacket is that's his special
school jacket it's almost like a
letterman jacket like his school wears
uniform it just meant to show you that
he's still in school like he wears a
special jacket there's a lot of kids all
over New York City to go to special
private schools that have to wear
jackets but if you look at the emblem
bonnet is very similar to the atom that
Tony Stark's father had when he was
making stark Expo so there might be some
special funding coming from the stark
family whether it be Howard Stark or
Tony Stark himself but I think part of
the reason for making the jacket yellow
is so that the yellow in red reminds you
of Ironman colors so there's no Ironman
in here but you see a whole lot of
Ironman Avengers Tower like he is
clinging to it in this picture here
there might even be a big action set
piece involving the Avengers Tower
there's a lot of Tony Stark in the last
trailer and I know we haven't seen
anything of his friend from Brooklyn but
the thing about this road sign that he's
hanging off of is it is off of the 495
which sort of connects midtown Manhattan
with like the Empire State Building over
here which means the Avengers Towers
right here
when Queens and Brooklyn adjacent so
this isn't saying that Captain America
is going to be in the film but it's just
reminding you winking that he has a
friend from Brooklyn and he is very
close to Brooklyn so think that for what
you will but most of the movie is going
to be focusing on Iron Man because we
have confirmed Robert Downey jr. in the
movie and we have the Avengers tower
front and center in what do the villains
of the movie look like they're doing
trying to evolve so we have the vulture
the tinkerer the shocker
and maybe the Prowler jury's still out
on Donald Glover's character but what do
they want they want shatori tech so that
they can upgrade themselves and pull
bigger crimes times are changing time we
change too so what would you find inside
the Avengers Tower you would find a lot
of Tony Stark's toys he probably did not
take everything with him when he moved
upstate so we might get to see an action
set piece involving the villains trying
to steal something from the Avengers
Tower spider-man trying to stop them
rewind to the last couple of spider-man
movies what's the big tech oriented
building the Spider Man spends a lot of
time in the Oscorp building there's a
bunch of research that's where he gets
his spider bite in the first amazing
spider-man movie so spider-man being a
very science or
oriented character he's sort of like a
junior science bro in training if they
wanted to mimic elements of previous
spider-man movies in this they would use
the Avengers tower as a stand-in for
what they used to use the Oscorp tower
for Tony Stark is always going to be a
hero there is Norman Osborn in this
universe he's too big of a spider-man
villain for them to not include him in
the movies at some point but I think way
back they were actually trying to get
Matthew McConaughey for a mystery
villain role in the Marvel Universe I
think it was Norman Osborn I think they
were trying to get him for the
spider-man movie before they got Michael
Keaton and then turned him into the
vulture just because it's a little more
age-appropriate for him I mean you could
argue whether or not he make a great
Norman Osborn because he's so good you
could turn him into the kangaroo and it
would still be an amazing performance
that's right there was a spider-man
villain called the kangaroo who just
left over things so based on all this
stuff as they're teasing it sounds like
we're going to see The Avengers tower at
some point in one of the trailers as
they drop maybe it'll be this next week
maybe it'll be one of the other trailers
but they're just going to be a whole
bunch of spider-man footage dropping in
the next couple months
just like guardians of the galaxy and
most of the marketing will come through
Sony first but it'll also be coming
through Marvel like Marvel uses all of
its social to promote spider-man stuff
so that actually reminds me if you guys
didn't know I do post a lot of updates
on videos and other stuff on Twitter
Facebook these are my links so you can
follow me here for updates on what
videos are coming especially when we
have crazy weekend's like this when
they're just like crazy stuff to get
through so there's so many videos that
you've requested I'm still trying to get
through that I'll post as quick as
possible in the next couple of days but
there's new Deadpool too and they have
this funny boss logic poster he makes
some of the best fan posters if you
actually fell in the East River
you would crawl out with mutant powers
that's how dirty it is there's some new
Logan I want to post though be some new
Justice League there's a bunch of DC and
Marvel so just look on my Twitter and
Facebook in that top comment that I pin
on what videos are going to post NYX but
be sure to leave me all your requests if
you're a subscriber like the only way I
know which videos you guys want me to
work on is if you tell me in the
comments what's going to happen later
tonight is Walking Dead is doing part
one of its two-part finale it's going to
be crazy so I'll post that video
congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Jack derp no you win
those spider-man action figures be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video I'll just announce
the winner the next time I post a Marvel
video thank you so much for watching
while you wait for that you can click
here to re-watch all that crazy Justice
League and you can click here to rewatch
that brand new guardians of the galaxy
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys in the next
video